smells like nothing I'm scared to open
it then it's gonna splash everywhere
gonna cry
[Music]
hi I'm AM ro and today I'm going to be
making koshary using my mom's recipe
koshary is also called the dish of the
poor because it only costs one dollar
the recipe is relatively easy it only
uses pasta or rice check peas lentil is
very vegetarian I have no knowledge in
cooking I only cook very basic stuff
cutting a salad so I made sure to talk
to my mom and get the right recipe the
reason why I'm doing this because I
haven't been back home for almost six
years I kind of want to just have hint
of home so I'm hoping to get this right
the relationship between me and my mom
was great up until a year and a half ago
I came out to her we kind of drifted
apart and you I needed the recipe from
my mom but I wasn't sure if if I'll be
able to call her or she would respond to
my texts tomorrow I'm gonna give her a
call
I'm waiting for my mom to call what do
you say hi hi what's up I know but this
will be cash a nice little minute solo
and a family video but book fee for
shitty appetizer flow
Tara Fiji do you need toyou have a
truxedo bye bye bye
everything is okay
life is good my relationship with my mom
is great I'm so happy okay cool first of
all we need to chop onions okay my mom
told me to cut it super thin slice and
then chop it a little bit the onions are
going to be fried why does it look easy
in movies or I mean at least when my mom
does it I really hope I look
professional because I'm gonna show this
video to my mom and I want her to be
like this is my son mom this is for you
so now I just have to keep doing this
just keep staring so now we're doing the
rice with lentil so I use only two cups
I think this is a lot I don't know my
mom told me to add two came in later I'm
almost like the best chef and I feel
like embarrassed I can't even remember
two steps smells like nothing that
smells so much like home nothing wrong
with that anymore so the only way I saw
my mom cooking is always like she only
feels it like oh let me just put this
much if I succeed in this I would feel
like I'm home and this is all I need
of course like not talking to her a year
and a half was stuff was kind of a big
deal because I've been calling her for
the past six years every single day or
like text at least going for a year and
a half without that conversation
definitely had an effect on me and I'm
sure I had an effect on her so now we're
going to do the sauce the smell is
magical it's literally you walk down the
street of Cairo you can smell Kishori
everywhere and I think it's all because
of the sauce if I nail this we have the
most amazing dish I'm not gonna put a
lot look volcano mmm smells so good from
just the smell I might have made my mom
proud so my mom talks about presentation
it's all about presentation spoon of
onion pasta I like pasta
I'll put a little bit more for me shake
beads
pretty much kind of level it up so this
is the moment of truth
[Music]
voila can I cry this looks so beautiful
this is exactly like my mom okay I'm
gonna put the sauce this is happening
you guys okay let's do it
I made a little spicy for my taste this
is so good this tastes exactly like
here's mom I got Vic Dominic she loved
it this is it this is it I'm very happy
[Music]